what i want to do in this video is prove
to you that the square root of two is
irrational
and i'm going to do this through a proof
by contradiction
and the proof by contradiction
is is set up by assuming the opposite
let's assume so this is what this is our
goal but for the sake of our proof let's
assume the opposite let's assume that
square root of two is rational
and then we'll see if we lead to a
contradiction that this actually cannot
be the case and if it cannot be the case
that it is rational if we get to a
contradiction by setting by assuming the
square root of 2 is rational then we
have to deduce that the square root of 2
must be irrational so let's let's assume
the opposite square root of 2 is
rational
well if the square root of 2 is rational
that means that we can write the square
root of 2
as the ratio of two integers
and b
a and b and we can also assume
we can also assume that these have no
factors in common let's say that they
did have some factors in common if we
divided the numerator and the
denominator by those same factors then
you're getting into a situation where
they have no factors in common or
another way of saying is that a and b
are co-prime or another way of saying is
we can write this as a ratio of two
integers where this is irreducible where
these no longer share any factors if you
can write anything as
the ratio of two integers then you can
obviously
simplify it further factor out any
common factors to get it to a point
where it is irreducible so i'm going to
assume that my a and b
that this fraction right over here is
irreducible and this is important for
our for setting up our contradiction so
i'm going to assume that this right over
here is irreducible
they have no factors a and b have no
factors in common let me write that down
just because that's so important for
this proof a and under that same color
a
and b
a and b have no factors in common
no
no factors in common
other than i guess one
common
no
factors in common other
than
one so this is irreducible these are
these two numbers are co prime
so what does that do for us well let's
just try to manipulate this a little bit
let's square both sides of this equation
so if you square the principal root of 2
you're going to get 2
and that's going to be equal to a
squared
over
b squared
a squared
over b squared and that just comes from
a over b squared is the same thing as a
squared over b squared and now we can
multiply both sides of this by b squared
and so we get
we get 2
times b squared
b squared is equal to
a squared
now what does this tell us about a
squared
well a squared is some number b squared
times two
so anything times two is going if you
this is going to be an integer we
assumed a we assumed b is an integer so
b squared must be an integer and so you
have an integer times 2 well that must
give you an even number that must give
you an even integer so this right over
here a squared must be so this tells us
this tells us that a squared must be a
squared
is
even
now why is that interesting
well a squared is the product of two
numbers or is its product of the same
number it's a times a so this is another
way of saying that a times a
is
even
so what does that tell us about a
well let's just remind ourselves a is
either going to be we're assuming a is
an integer a is either going to be even
or odd we just have to remind ourselves
if we multiply an even
times an even
and even times an even we get an even
number if we multiply an odd
times an odd
we get an odd number
we get an odd number so we have a number
times itself we got an even number well
the only way to get that is if that
number is even
so this tells us this tells us that a
a
is
even
and another way of saying that a is even
is to say that a can be represented that
a can be represented as the product of
two times some integer
so let's say some integer some integer k
so i know well where is all this going
well as you'll see we can then use this
to show that b must also be even so
let's let's think about that a little
bit so let's go back to this step right
over here if we say that a can be
represented as 2 times a product of some
integer and that comes out of the fact
that a is even
then we could rewrite this expression
right over here as 2. i'll do it over
here 2
2 times b squared
2 times b squared is equal to
2k squared is instead of a squared i
could write 2k squared
we're claiming or we're deducing that
assuming everything we've just assumed
that a is even so if a is even it can be
represented as a product of 2 and some
integer and then we can write
we can write that 2 times b squared
2 times b squared is equal to
is equal to 4k squared
4
k squared and then you divide both sides
by 2 you get b squared
b squared is equal to 2k squared
is equal to 2
times k squared
and this tells us that well you know k
squared is going to be an
integer you take any integer times 2
you're going to get an even value so
this tells us that b squared is even
b squared
b squared is even
so that tells us that b squared is even
well if b squared is even by the same
logic we just used that tells us that b
is even
b is even
so here's our contradiction
we
we assumed in the beginning that a and b
have no common factors other than one we
assumed that this fraction right over
here a over b is irreducible but from
that and the fact that a over b must be
equal to the square root of 2 we were
able to deduce that a is even and b is
even well if a is even and b is even
then they both have two as a factor then
this isn't irreducible you could divide
the numerator and the denominator by two
a and b have a common factor of two so
that's so let me write this down so this
is just to make it clear so from from
this
and this
we have a and b
have common factor
common
factor
of 2
which means that a over b is reducible
and so that's the contradiction
that's the contradiction
so you assume
that squared 2 can be represented by as
an irreducible fraction a over b
irreducible you say ratio of two
integers right over here that leads you
to the contradiction that no it actually
can be reducible so therefore you cannot
make this assumption it leads to a
contradiction square root of 2 must be
irrational